souriez vous êtes filmés de plus en plus
de caméras sont installées dans l'espace
public
objectif assurer la protection des biens
et des personnes avons nous notre mot à
dire eh bien on va en savoir plus tout
de suite avec maître jean luc chaumar
souriez vous êtes filmés
surtout sur ce plateau avait pas
l'espace public mais c'est pourquoi
alors si près d'un million à deux
caméras étaient installées dans l'espace
public en 2012 selon la cnil aujourd'hui
forcément c'est beaucoup plus de
nombreuses villes installe des systèmes
de vidéoprotection exemple à anould
verre ou la police municipale en mai la
charge regardez ce reportage prendre en
parle après des gestes précis assurer un
rituel quotidien que le chef de service
tronet chien qui a évolué depuis près de
15 ans gilet pare balles puis armes à
feu la procédure de préparation déjà
jungle la police municipale d'univers
s'intensifie cette forme 99 de 69 et
depuis peu une étape supplémentaire
la vérification du système de
vidéoprotection 28 caméra postée dans
les endroits clés de la ville hôte en
deuil qui enregistre pour prévenir c'est
une sécurité plus je dirais plus plus
par rapport aux agents qui sont sur le
terrain par rapport aux administrés qui
sont sur le sur la voie publique par
rapport aux services de police aussi
drapeau tout ce qui est en quête
judiciaire derrière et qui permet
aujourd'hui on va de pouvoir confondre
l'auteur beaucoup plus rapidement que
par le passé des bords de loire au
centre ville le matériel s'adapter
devient tout terrain
et les nouveaux dispositifs rassure les
verts soient consultés en réunion
publique poche plus tôt pour en fait
parce que comme simple exemple si jamais
un jour on se fait voler notre téléphone
portable on peut facilement retrouver la
personne les choses comme ça pour
pouvoir d'ingérence dans la vie
particulière des gens c'est juste pour
rassurer c'est un outil parmi d'autres
un outil qui a coûté 460 mille euros
dont 40 % provient du fonds
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance
ce qui exaspère nos concitoyens qui soit
à nos verres ou ailleurs c'est notamment
les petites incivilités et bien sûr les
actes des découpes délinquance plus
graves atteintes à la personne aux
atteintes aux biens et le pire de tous
et je vous le dis aussi en tant
qu'avocat c'est l'impunité l'impunité le
premier facteur de récidive
un bilan régulier devrait permettre
d'évaluer rapidement l'impact de ce
système de vidéoprotection dans l'espace
public on est d'accord on parle bien de
vidéoprotection et non pas de vidéo
surveillance
c'est de la sémantique tout ça les tj ou
dans les administrations parle de
vidéoprotection ça fait moins peur que
quand on parle de vidéosurveillance
parce que vidéosurveillance ça veut dire
qu'on surveille
alors pour que la pose des caméras
soient dégâts la ville doit répondre à
des obligations qu'elles font appel aux
en fait vous avez une sorte de grille on
va être le plus simple possible dès lors
que vous êtes dans un lieu public ouvert
au public dans lequel le public va
pouvoir se mouvoir très librement
vous devez obtenir une autorisation de
la préfecture et donc démarches
administratives à à réaliser quand vous
êtes dans un lieu privé et que ce lieu
privé va simplement accueillir du public
mais de façon privée alors vous n'avez
qu'une déclaration à effectuer auprès de
la commission nationale informatique et
libertés exemple un restaurant ou un
magasin c'est ça alors un restaurant un
magasin s'est ouvert au public donc
autorisation on va prendre l'exemple
d'une école une école va mettre des
caméras
l'entrée de l'école sur l'espace public
là il va falloir de obtenir une
autorisation parce que c'est un lieu
public à l'intérieur de l'école on est
on accueille du public mais c'est devenu
un lieu privé alors la déclaration
auprès de la cnil suffit si on vient
vraiment sur l'espace avec l'egypte
la vie peut mettre le nombre de caméras
cas une autorisation
bien sûr elle peut mettre le nombre de
caméras qu'elle veut et on va prendre
l'exemple de dijon dans dijon vous avez
des caméras qui se trouvent dans des
endroits spécifiques et quant aux
plusieurs fois des question était posée
de savoir s'il fallait mettre des
caméras dans des lieux prétendument
sensibles ou dans des quartiers dits
sensibles
le maire de dijon répondait mais je
n'entends pas mettre des caméras partout
équipe l installation on entendu dans le
reportage une partie qui vient du fonds
interministériel de prévention la
délinquance et l'autre et bien d'autres
c'est vous c'est moi ce sont nos impôts
et une question aussi quitté revient
souvent est ce que la vie enfin en tout
cas c'est vidéosurveillance on est ce
que les images peuvent être stockées
alors là encore il y a des règles
évidemment pour jamais perdre de vue que
on est en conflit
en étant conflit entre cette nécessité
de surveiller d'éviter de protéger le
public dans un espace public
et puis ce conflit il est avec quelque
chose qui est aussi importante c'est la
vie privée de chacun qu'il faut savoir
respecter
on a le droit de filmer et de stocker
les images
selon l'autorisation qui nous est
accordée par la préfecture
en tout cas jamais plus d'un mois ça
veut dire que si un délit commis est
constatée par ces caméras on peut alors
on peut s'en servir le délai du mois
dans le délai du mois
en lieu ensuite on a des exceptions
imaginons qu'une infraction soit commise
qu'un juge d'instruction soit saisi
il a besoin de l'a22 des images de vidéo
protection de vidéosurveillance il va en
demander
il va demander accès à ces à ces
éléments là qui bien entendu vont être à
sa disposition plus d'un mois mais le
stockage et lui c'est pas plus d'un mois
là on a parlé donc de l'espace public
des restaurants des magasins je suis un
particulier je laissais de mettre des
caméras chez moi j'ai le droit sans en
aviser la cnil bah oui parce que là vous
êtes chez vous vous protégez votre vie
privée comme vous voulez si vous voulez
vous filmez vous même les hits et pas à
la maison bien entendu si vous avez un
salarié à la maison vous devenez
employeurs évidemment et en étant
employeur il va falloir respecter
notamment le code du travail et le code
du travail prévoit aussi la protection
de la vie privée des salariés
et là nous sommes dans une situation un
petit peu différente c'est à dire que en
matière de droit du travail
celui qui veut mettre en place une
surveillance au sein de l'entreprise
pour surveiller son salarié notamment va
devoir le prévenir négocier travaillé en
amont avec lui il ne s'agira pas
simplement d'une autorisation
il s'agirait il s'agira d'une
négociation d'une affirmation préalable
à tout le moins elle s'il ne fait pas ça
eh bien il va être trop il va tomber
sous le coup de la loi c'est à dire que
des sanctions existent
on peut en effet saisir la cnil saisir
la préfecture et saisir le juge pour
faire respecter son droit à la vie
privée
merci beaucoup m lexmark pour toutes ces
explications